so how will the gop capitalize on these
23 outgoing democrats so they can
actually retake the house house minority
whip steve scalise joins me now so
congressman i know that you see the data
you see the polling right do you see a
red wave coming for republicans in 2022
hey great to be with you sean and what
you see on the ground is a lot of energy
and enthusiasm on the republican side
you saw it happen in virginia but even
in other states where you saw kind of
the preview of what could come next year
i think it's a lot like 2010 the year
that you were elected to congress and we
flipped 63 seats from democrat to
republican in that big wave i think you
know 63 might not be the number but i
think you're going to see a lot of seats
competitive and as you were talking
about there was retirements the real
retirements to watch sean are swing
district democrats that are announcing
that they're retiring stephanie murphy
was mentioned i think that's a seat we
can flip in florida in your home state
of wisconsin ron khan was one of the
first people to announce that they're
retiring we've got a great candidate
derek van orden who's been out working
hard and i think he can flip that seat
we have great candidates all across the
board it starts with great candidates
and a great message people don't like
this big government socialism they're
rejecting it in every state from blue
states to red states but with great
candidates we have a great fundraising
advantage moving forward and we're not
going to slow down we're going to be
working very hard next year not only to
show how bad they're doing people
already get the inflation the spending
and all the crazy policies but also what
are going to be those bold conservative
items we're going to be rolling that out
next year as well
so so steve you just mentioned the the
cash right so we all know that in
campaigns it takes money to win you have
to you know put ads on tv you ha you
have to get mail um and if you don't
have money you can't actually get your
message out how do how are republicans
doing right now compared to democrats on
the cash front
well sean we've been breaking records
and out raising the democrats almost
every month and by the way they're in
the majority they have the house senate
and white house and we've been out
raising them almost every month this
year you're seeing people come in and
donate money in large numbers who in
some cases who never did before because
they're scared to death about the future
of the country they don't want america
to become a socialist nation they're
tired of all the spending that's jacking
up inflation and it's not just big
donors by the way we're getting record
numbers of small donors people giving 20
a person you can go to steve scalise.com
and give 20 right now it's going to go
to help fire nancy pelosi and help us
win back the house we're seeing records
being broken on fundraising i think
because people are excited about our
great conservative candidates the
prospect of what we will do to reverse
this big government socialism we're
seeing
yeah i think what's interesting is there
is a lot of small dollar contributions
that are coming in in the five
ten you know forty dollars but let me
ask you about this because um you look
at the failures of democrats whether
it's the border or crime or afghanistan
inflation energy i mean there's not
really any successes for them to run on
and so when you hear them talk they'll
say the salvation for our electoral
chances in in the midterms in 2022 is we
have to pass build back better the
socialist massive spending package
and frankly i mean i i look at that and
go are they blind do they not see that
the american people don't want more
borrowing and more spending and more
programs they want to be able to buy
food at the grocery store they won't be
able to fill up their
their car with gas and not get gouged i
mean it seems that they're completely
out of touch with the american people
they're incredibly out of touch sean and
you saw it in the exit polling in
virginia you know and yunkan ran a great
race terry mcauliffe when he said
parents shouldn't be involved in their
kids education that was a bellwether
he's not the only one by the way that is
kind of the mantra of a lot of these big
government socialists it's about
government control but democrats a week
after the virginia election pass the
four and a half trillion dollar bill i
mean they they won't stop spending money
and everybody knows it's driving
inflation and what is their answer to
keep trying to spend more money at least
in the senate joe manchin said enough is
enough they won't even listen to him
they're calling him every name in the
book uh they just want they want power
they want control over people's lives
people just want freedom it's why
they're flocking to the states like
florida and texas that are open and
they're fleeing in droves from states
like in new york and california and
illinois they're shutting everything
down
you know congressman i i think that it's
great to run a campaign that says i'm
just not a democrat right now and that
can work but you do have to have an
agenda to run on in the one of we
support freedom we support individual
choice would be a successful mantra for
republicans to hit across the country as
you come into the midterms but listen
thanks for joining me tonight i
appreciate it congressman
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else